the house of representatives will be
voting later this month
on whether to make washington d.c the
51st
state of the united states cbs news
reporting
that house majority leader steny hoyer
wrote in a letter to colleagues two
three days ago that at some point during
april the house will hold a vote
do we make washington dc the 51st
state now of course of course of course
it will almost certainly pass the house
and it will almost certainly go nowhere
in the senate most republicans have
expressed
that they are against making washington
dc
the 51st state this would not be and
will not be the first time that the
house of representatives votes to do
this the house already approved the dc
statehood measure in 2020 by a vote of
232
to 180 but it did not even come to the
floor of the senate now
in 2020 the senate was controlled by
republicans
democrats now control the senate it's 50
50
democrats have a majority because by
controlling the white house kamala
harris becomes
the tie-breaking 51st vote in the senate
but
most legislation needs 60 votes to go
forward
this is not the type of thing making
washington dc a 51st state
that's not something you can move
forward on via budget reconciliation by
every analysis that we've seen so far
so you need to find 10 republicans 10
republicans
and it is extraordinarily unlikely we
are not aware
of 10 republicans that want to move
forward with washington d.c as a 51st
state
senate majority leader chuck schumer has
committed to bringing it to the floor
for a vote
but again this gets back to the
filibuster and we when we talked
uh what was it january maybe february
when we talked about the possible paths
forward on the filibuster uh
one of the things that we explained was
even if there's something you could pass
with 50 votes you still need 60 to end
debate
this is how this is how the filibuster
works and we talked about some
filibuster reforms making it a talking
filibuster
requiring 40 um requiring 40
of senators in the senate to keep debate
going at all times
we've talked about all these things none
of these changes have been made and so
we listed dc statehood and puerto rican
statehood as
specific possible issues that will go
nowhere
unless some kind of filibuster reform is
done well it's happening now
sometime this month the house is going
to vote on making washington dc
a 51st state it is likely to pass it
will then go to the senate and by every
indication there will not even be a vote
on it uh of course i am in favor of dc
statehood we've talked before about how
the population of washington dc at 700
000 is larger than the population of the
state of wyoming which has
uh two senators it's larger than the
population of the state of vermont which
has two senators
those in washington dc have no voting
representation
in congress but they do have
just as a sort of factual note eleanor
holmes norton
is a representative for washington d.c
in the house but is a non-voting
delegate so that's the latest i've said
i would love to see this issue of dc
statehood dealt with in a serious manner
by joe biden
um the house is going to vote and then
it is likely going to stall in the
senate and at a certain point
democrats and joe biden are going to
have to decide
are we committed to getting these things
done to the degree that we are going to
do something about the filibuster
understanding that any changes they do
make to the filibuster could be a
double-edged sword
that comes back against them when they
are not in control
i support filibuster reform i support
washington d.c as a 51st state
i would love to hear from you how should
democrats handle this
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that
helix has launched a new company called
all form which makes
premium customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room
at home it's now my favorite piece of
furniture in the house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built
it's huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get twenty percent off your
entire order when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video